[Música]
[Aplausos]
cuál es el parásito más resistente una
bacteria un virus una teniente final
una idea resistente altamente contagiosa
una vez que una idea se apodera del
cerebro es casi imposible erradicarla
una idea completamente formada que se
aferra ahora si prefieren irse por el
lado más técnico de acuerdo al
diccionario de google una idea es una
representación mental de algo ya sea
material o inmaterial real o imaginario
concreto o abstracto a la que se llega a
través de la observación de distintos
fenómenos
un poco complicado no pero no se
preocupen que hoy no venimos a hablarles
sobre los tecnicismos que rodean el
concepto de la idea sino más bien os
estaremos enfocando en qué es lo que les
puede afectar al tratar de desarrollar
esa idea para nosotras las ideas son la
razón de la existencia de todo y a pesar
de que son el fruto de todo lo que
tocamos y vemos no dejan de ser un
simple pensamiento que puede perderse
para siempre sentimos que en el mundo
hay ideas muy buenas que simplemente
viven en silencio dentro de mente está
en cosas pero por el hecho del que hay
trabajo con limitaciones en el camino
opuestas ya sea por la sociedad o uno
mismo es que nunca ven la luz del día
entonces cuál es el verdadero proceso
para lograr una idea hay que entender
que los procesos creativos son únicos
hasta los problemas con los que pasamos
pueden ser iguales pero también no todos
tenemos la misma vida
para hacer esta charla todos pasamos por
procesos diferentes aunque tengamos un
objetivo en común pero es importante
recalcar t
la idea no es tenerla sino cumplirlas
ahora nos adentramos un obstáculo tengo
una idea y sé lo que quiero hacer pero
nadie cree en mí esto puede parecer
irrelevante para muchas personas pero la
verdad es que cuando te validan a ti a
tu idea hay mucha motivación a un
proyecto puede que tu idea no sea del
agrado de tus amigos tu familia tus
compañeros de trabajo o tus maestros
pero sabes que no importa lo que tienes
que hacer ahora es encontrar esa gente
que sí cree en ti y no dejarla ir
obviamente es difícil pero la verdad tú
no vives por la aprobación de los demás
a la única persona a la que le tiene que
gustar tu idea es a ti porque así como
habrá gente que la amara habrá gente que
lo hará porque las ideas son como pulgas
saltan de unos a otros pero no pican a
todos
usted no suena aquí para las inseguras
de lo que hablaba
más o menos lo que no saben es que a
firmes ni siquiera queríamos formar
parte de este proyecto
ambas teníamos muy ambiciosas que
tendríamos que estar apoyadas y
decidimos no pero la segunda vez que se
nos preguntó nos dijimos y si lo hacemos
juntas que nada malo podía salir bueno
apuntadas a dos personas caminan
maletica de trabajo
podríamos ser el apoyo que la otra
necesitaba ese pequeño empujón para
animarnos a hacer nuestra plática hubo
momentos en los que uno dudaba de ella
misma y era la otra la que le aseguraba
que todo iba a estar bien y tan solo
tener ese pequeño apoyo y un largo
camino y sin duda alguna fue lo que nos
trajo estar aquí frente a ustedes en
este momento esperamos que entiendan que
nunca están solos
nada más necesitan encontrar a veces a
una persona justa disfruta creer en
ustedes y en su idea para llevarla
adelante como lo hicimos nosotras a
medida que nos animábamos más a hacer
esta plática llegaron nuevos problemas y
la típica pregunta de qué van a hablar
teníamos una lista de ideas que fuimos
descartando en base a que les va a
interesar
como público y nos interesaba a nosotras
y que podría ser más visto por la
institución
tristemente muchas de nuestras ideas no
pasaron este último corte y no sean como
nosotras nos asustamos de hablar de algo
que en realidad nos apasionaba por miedo
a ser juzgadas o como podíamos ser
vistas dejamos que opiniones ajenas se
metieran en nuestra cabeza y nos
afectaran y por favor no dejen que suele
suceder ustedes yo sé que parece difícil
pero lo mejor que pueden hacer es
ignorar toda esa negatividad y no
temerle intentar porque al adentrarnos a
lo desconocido es como descubrimos las
cosas todos tenemos derecho a hablar
pero ten en cuenta que lo tenemos que
hacer con respeto a todos
mi idea puede ser revolucionaria pero
igualmente podría ser tomada como
controversial en comunidad y eso fue
exactamente lo que pasó con martín
julián él sabía que tenía una idea digna
de ser escuchadas obviamente eran
derechos humanos pero nunca se rindió a
tratar de transmitirla y nunca pero
nunca le faltó el respeto a alguien lo
que estamos tratando de transmitir es
que el hecho de que pueda ser silenciado
no significa que debas de parar con tu
idea porque después de todo tienes que
creer en ella y apostarlo todo para no
quedarte con el hubiera porque recuerda
que no existe nada tan peligroso como
una idea amplia en cerebros estrechos
finalmente viene nuestro problema
favorito la procrastinación esto que
hemos tenido al menos una experiencia
con la procrastinación en la que
quisimos dejar lo escolar y quien me
dijo yo sé que está ciego aunque
confiamos en que saben lo que es les
digo la definición exacta el pro casting
ar es el hábito o acción de posponer
actividades que tienen que ser atendidas
urgentemente sustituyéndolas por otras
más agradables e irrelevantes esto puede
ser por simple miedo afrontar la
demasiada confianza en nosotros mismos
este tiene que ser el problema número
uno de sal que sujetan que ha trabajado
o ido a la escuela es decir que
determinan si tienes tu diploma se han
iniciado un día antes proyectos que
valen encima posible tu calificación se
han empezado cuatro horas antes de la
clase hablamos por experiencia y
reportes de trabajo se ha entregado
media hora media hora tarde por haberlos
iniciado ese mismo día ahora se estarán
preguntando qué exactamente tiene que
ver esto con una idea sencillo puede que
tú tengas un proyecto que hacer o una
plática que dar pero por el simple hecho
de que crees demasiado en ti mismo para
dejarlo hasta la fecha límite o tiene
esperanza de hacerlo la mente informarte
que estás pro casting 'no y no estás
dando tu mejor trabajo muchas personas
luchan con este problema pero no estás
se han dedicado a tratar de resolverlo y
una idea que nos gusta mucho a nosotras
es la regla de 5 segundos propuesta por
la autora - robin la regla de cinco
segundos es fácil simplemente cuando
surge el momento de tomar esa decisión o
empezar tu trabajo deja de pensar
empieza una cuenta regresiva
4 3 2 1 y hazlo o decide ya qué
funcionar porque es tu corazón y
tránsito tomando la decisión no lógica
que es lo que te lleva a pensar
demasiado en algo y te remueve la cabeza
pero bueno como humanos estamos en
constante evolución no eres la misma
persona que eras hace tres meses y por
eso nuestra forma de pensar tiene que ir
cambiando a medida que la sociedad
avanza o acaso tendría sentido pensar
como hace 20 años todas las ideologías
incluso la de las comunidades más
conservadoras tienen que ir cambiando
porque todas las ideas incluso las
sagradas deben adaptarse a nuevas
realidades
pierde al miedo al qué dirán ya que en
un futuro te vas a arrepentir no haber
hecho o dicho eso que querías también un
cabezas a las personas que te apoyan
porque ellas son tu roca y tú de
asegurar es la de ellos por último
recuerda que la ciudad son lo que hacen
que sigamos creciendo como personas y a
veces la gente les tiene miedo porque
les asusta el cambio se rehúsan escuchar
algo que no sé lo que ya están
acostumbrados y rechazan lo desconocido
varias veces te van a decir que nunca
vas a triunfar y que deberías de
rendirte pero no importa lo que digan
las ideas y las palabras si cambien al
mundo gracias
[Aplausos]